hello and welcome to this video playing
yeah this is one of those names that I
cannot pronounce so what did we have I
have won a black game there and this one
okay so again they accelerate this is
somehow really in fashion okay let's see
how black improves like compared to the
game before okay that looks like like he
knows some some theory him and I am know
that I'm playing this move but I have
forgotten the details this is always
good by the way if you know that you
play a certain move but you don't quite
remember how it works you should not
spend ages working it out over the board
just play it yeah you're oftentimes will
be yeah you will be yeah you're thinking
okay what am I said again and then
you're absolutely losing the plot okay
so um
[Music]
26 so I can get yet another tempo with
94 yeah is that true I can also take but
why not 94 okay let's take this tempo
okay so Queen to b3 even or just take it
I can just take it right
so it's t5 research something I mean
it's it's a move that I can only play
now so I should do it problem
so what's going on here I think I'll
take him
Queen takes would have been interesting
okay so check know what
yeah probably canceling one idea is that
Knight f6 I will take and play Bishop h6
so that that must be really excellent
the question is is there something like
a rook da door okay like it's not really
trying to to challenge me here maybe
there was no real way to do that but
rook the 8 is still the thing maybe this
is possible I'm not saying it's entirely
impossible that this is going to work I
mean I cannot cover the pawn but you
would think that there is some way to
punish black for for this way of playing
so a queen move yeah Mac we move so that
after Queen takes d5 I have room have
lucrative one so maybe Queen to e2 would
be good to have more time to consider it
but it's just not the case
so which look I'm not sure that it is
important
I wonder if Queen to h5 is an option
sort of trying to yeah taking the bishop
and then looking it a bit more difficult
for me yeah this is going to be very
dangerous for me anyway where is he or
she going five okay it's no castling for
you check
okay so Quincy for I will a Quincy force
is actually wait if I am you know I
should really be looking at this for a
moment because it looks very close to
something something devastating check
here maybe
Queenie six then I mean this is good but
not sure its best the thing got Roxie
one not so as a threat see no better
move unfortunately and he is got rooked
e8 which is a real chain
yeah yeah man I tried to kill black and
then my time management got to me and
there was a killer I mean we in via I'm
not discussing that absolutely it was an
unplayable position for sure unless it
was a very sometimes they are those
freakish situation where something looks
completely terrible and somehow not um
yeah it's very disappointing really
they blundered b21 which was not did not
need to give that up
still not a super easy win but I'm kind
of surprised that black is taking so
long now what is the most time chief fun
edge form I have got no square I mean
you won which is terrible
pretty awful game ready
Jim try to hang on
try to get some home to play with Quincy
AIDS
or this one threatening made so the ship
[Music]
my queen is six and playing this like a
complete idiot yet Wow giving him giving
him all this all these things and now
it's coveting that really should be and
that was terrible
you don't even think I'm gonna see
anymore maybe I'm maybe I am still worse
with a five yeah anyway but I mean black
should never survive this after this
atrocious opening play okay anyway so
let's see how I could have killed black
that that's really interesting to check
maybe here Queenie five was a problem
anyway yeah ed was a problem so what was
sort was best there Queen b3 and it's
over basically or what more castles yeah
I mean it like is just moving the Queen
around with no purpose so I really want
to know how I could have played this
because I simply cannot accept that this
is a but that's not going to go so like
plus a millionaire
rookie one wasn't best Queen c2 was best
and that wins okay this is really
amazing that this is not totally winning
because I mean it's so close you know
the bishop coming here would immediately
kill him and it's just like the the King
has no squares it's just like it's
hanging by a thread ready this is the
only move and then hear you he needs
route the aid because of my back rank
yeah so that this is still not totally
falling apart
and of course it was pretty awful here
to just drop me to him I mean my Queen
f7 is so good yeah but I was I was
really really annoyed by that time that
this game was actually still going on
and here it is objectively won't be very
bad and they have no time I wasn't
really thinking that he played it well
here but it's probably okay right the
bishop on behave is covering that and he
can't push the airport
that's probably no wave really for me to
stop it there's always screen to a six
and then the pawn is this rolling yeah
and now this is you just have to kill it
kill em on of 20 or something this is
just terrible you have to go to some
safe square and like move the Queen
around all the time so maybe castling is
best M because I mean black doesn't have
a move really night I have six I take
played Bishop h6 you know yeah it should
be really over in the opening yeah he
already went Queen cake so I was
thinking I check with like here and now
this is both hanging and it's really not
clear it would have a good solution him
yeah I should just cancel here I mean he
cannot go Bishop g4 because of Bishop f7
and 90 f6 I can take so d5 was I was
probably a bit too eager to punish him
and this is also thing I mean what do
you do now
engine wants to give away of seven
already yeah yeah that's bad time you
should never get get a game there okay
guys thanks for watching